Picador alright then no that's my dork
pick another door what's wrong with you
you know what you were right this is
your door
what's the matter you got a lot of bad
guys behind that door
[Music]
[Applause]
access granted access denied access
denied access denied blue cops and
Turkish or we've got unfinished business
sure sister took something from me a
virus could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
you wanna tell me just what we're
dealing with here it's my sister family
is
when it's the fate of the world it
becomes my business his whole thing
sounds really dodgy look off new system
listen I'll handle it the only way we
survive this working together like a
team let's do this buckle up that way
whoa see the look on his face you have
no idea how long I've been waiting to do
that
the music's already started
I see we can get it sick so you guys are
being hunted by an army of mercenaries
led by a genetically enhanced soldier
look at me I'm Brock Superman pretty
crazy
yeah he really is black Superman you
need to get off the grid we're home my
babies come home I'm sorry to bring
trouble here mama
but I need my brothers this family is
going to war we're gonna need cars and
guns
mama where's all our guns okay read up
on very noble mrs. Hobbs no answer is
trouble
yes understatement that's good old
school alright
we're going for a ride
somebody's just not happening
you